okay it has completely fallen apart for
actor jussie Smollett last month the
news was that Jesse Smollett was
attacked in a racist homophobic incident
the story we were told was that Smollett
was out getting something to eat when
two white men racially insulted him said
homophobic things punched him through a
chemical atom and put a rope around his
neck saying this is Magga country now
the story very quickly started to fall
apart
surveillance footage was found of two
brothers who are small its former or
sometimes personal trainer and someone
who also worked as an extra on Empire
the show that Smollett is on they were
on surveillance video buying ski masks
that looked like the ones ultimately
worn by the attackers the police say
that they now know that Smollett spoke
to the attackers on the phone both
before and after the incident and police
have now announced that felony charges
are forthcoming against Smollett the
technicality of it is disorderly conduct
and filing a false police report and
small it has indeed now been arrested
earlier today so this is all really
really really bad and of course Smollett
is innocent until proven guilty but
there is no serious defense of this at
this point in time even the statements
from smallest lawyers are merely
pointing to innocent until proven guilty
is a thing and not refuting the facts of
it in any way a quote from small its
attorneys Todd Pugh and Victor Henderson
says like any other citizen mr. Smollett
enjoys the presumption of innocence
particularly when there has been an
investigation like this one where
information both true and false has
repeatedly been leaked so it is not
looking good and for me there's a couple
of what I would consider the most
important elements here so the first
thing is this story is notable because
lots of other actors voiced support for
Smollett and now there are people
particularly on the American right who
are criticizing actors that voiced
support for
because they didn't question the facts
of the story it's not a super fair
criticism right I mean most crimes that
are reported are real if you find out
that a colleague makes an allegation
like this one ninety-nine percent of
normal people would say that's horrible
I wasn't there but they have my support
and what we're told happened is
absolutely deplorable and I hope that
people who did it are held accountable
if it turns out to be false which is
rare okay you say that's terrible of
false crime reporting is a crime and
there are going to be consequences for
that if I were presented by a newspaper
with a request for comment because
imagine that Tom Hartman radio host was
attacked in some other part of the
country and I get a call from a
newspaper and they say hey you know Tom
you've known him for years what do you
think I would say what is being reported
is absolutely horrible I feel terribly
for Tom he's a great guy and he has my
support if I later learned Tom staged
the attack I revised my statements but
it would be odd for me to at the
beginning say I'm suspicious that Tom
may have staged the attack it's just not
a reasonable standard so I don't think
that's the most fair critique most crime
reports are real
the second issue here is the idea of
people getting away with false crime
reporting and false rape reporting as
some kind of serious epidemic in the
United States of America there's no
evidence that people are getting away
with this in any significant numbers and
in fact this fell apart right small it
isn't getting away with it and that's
why much like when we talk about false
rape reports or in-person voter fraud
when people actually try to do it very
often they're caught and they suffer the
consequences and we have systems in
place to punish people who falsely
report crimes so I don't think Pat that
that's really a fair criticism that this
illuminates the epidemic of false crime
reporting he got caught the system work
is designed this sort of overlaps with
what you said there I've been watching a
lot of right-wing media accounts on this
and they claim that this
extends far beyond just small it that
this is part of the left-wing Hollywood
victim culture and the oppression
Olympics do you buy that explanation at
all no I don't I really don't and this
was we now are learning that the
motivation here was that small it wasn't
happy with his salary on Empire and he
in some kind of harebrained way believed
that this would allow him to get a
higher salary as one possibility I think
that the bottom line is that this is
someone who has some pretty serious
issues I'm going to show you just a few
seconds you know he is an actor this is
an interview he gave to Robin Roberts
where he acted like it was real and it's
sort of chilling to watch it now knowing
that it appears to have been totally
staged I'm pissed off what is it that
has you so angry is it that the attacker
is the attackers but it's also the
attacks it's like you know at first it
was a thing of like listen if I tell the
truth then that's it because it's the
truth then it became a thing of like oh
how can you doubt that like how do you
how do you not believe that it's the
truth and then it became a thing of like
oh it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth you don't
even want to see the truth I spoke to
some of my attorney friends this morning
and they said if they were defending him
in this case they would argue some kind
of mental illness that he didn't know
what he was doing that he's troubled
it's sort of hard to argue that though
when there was apparently so much so
much planning and premeditation we'll
see what happens make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show for the
latest show updates we will take a quick
break and be back after this one of
today's sponsors pres about is offering
you some free stuff that I want to tell
you about spresso box is based in New
York City they help keep guys wardrobes
fresh without breaking the bank because
when you become a member of spresso box
each month you'll get a new box sent to
your door
filled with five or six stylish
hand-picked accessories and pieces of
clothing
for men it includes high-end socks
neckties really nice sunglasses wallets
watches bracelets high-quality pens and
hair combs it's really classy stuff that
makes it easy to put a little more pop
into your wardrobe without having to
spend a ton of money a subscription is
just 25 bucks a month but your new box
every single month is guaranteed to have
items with a combined value of over $100
a couple of the things I got are a
really nice money clip a pocket square
and some great socks go check out the
different things that they put in their
monthly boxes they have a lot of really
nice-looking stuff everyone in our
audience can get one month totally free
when you click the link underneath this
video and use the promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma N